on the 24th of november 27 people died
when their boat capsized in the english
channel
it was the biggest loss of life in those
waters in recent history
just two people survived
those survivors said they waited for
help for hours in the dark
and claimed britain and france both
disagreed whose waters the struggling
boat was in
policy foreign
using marine tracking data
testimony from survivors and what
authorities say happened
sky news has learnt how the tragedy
unfolded
between 8 and 9 pm on the 23rd of
november a small dinghy leaves from
lumplage an area between calais and
dunkirk a man who survived the incident
said the dinghy started experiencing
problems at 1 30 am having been at sea
for four hours he says between 2 15 and
2 45 am the engines stopped working
using marine traffic data
sky news has highlighted specific boats
in the channel
at 3 am you can see uk border force boat
hmc valiant and flamont of the french
navy in the channel
for scale these boats are about 8 miles
apart
at the same time a french fishing boat
the san jacques de is heading north keep
an eye on this because it will become a
key part of this story
45 minutes later the lid uk search and
rescue helicopter is in the channel
we can see it here moving around most
likely responding to other rescues
with no precise location a small boat in
the darkness of the channel like the
dinghy would have been very difficult to
make out from the air
between the early hours of the morning
and lunchtime there is a gap in what we
know
it's not until 12 58 pm 11 hours after
it got into difficulty that the dinghy
is spotted by the fishing boat sanjak
dur
it phones it into the french coast guard
and report seeing bodies motionless in
the sea
the french coast guard then reports the
incident to the uk coast guard
there are french and british vessels in
the area
just two miles away is the boat flamont
labelled here as french warship
we can also see border force boat hunter
in uk territorial waters
after eight minutes the mayday call goes
out from the french coast guard acronym
15
man overboard approximately 15 men
overboard all ships in this area are
requested to have a short lookout to
break it to this area they quote these
coordinates
this location is in french territorial
waters but less than a mile from uk
waters the direction of the wind and
currents would have been pushing the
dinghy back towards france
the fact they gave the location is
significant given that the french coast
guard had actually given the specific
location
and had put a mayday call out to
a whole search and rescue area
i would suggest that that is a friend
giving permission to uh
any
vessel in that location in that locality
to enter
french territorial waters to rescue the
dinghy a number of boats including a uk
trawler and four french fishing boats
can be seen here they're within five
miles of the mayday location four
minutes after the mayday call the uk
search and rescue helicopter from lid
lifts it can be seen here
ten minutes later the french coast guard
boat escao launches from dunkirk
at 205 french rescue boat notre dame de
response launches from cali port the
rescue effort continues throughout the
afternoon and into the early evening
but by now it's clear this is a recovery
operation
secretary
the home office says the incident was in
french waters
and the uk coast guard provided help as
soon as it was requested by the french
but experts say where the incident took
place is not relevant so as far as
rescuing people at sea
uh is concerned
we need to think about
two areas of
the sea one is the peripheral waters and
the other is the search and rescue area
states are responsible for their search
and rescue area and this area can extend
beyond
the parrotborough waters once the french
coast guard put out the mayday call any
uk boats close enough could have helped
unless
they would have put themselves
passengers or their vessel in danger
the tracking data only gives us a
snapshot of what happened
but one thing is clear
if the dinghy passengers had been found
in the water earlier
the outcome would have been very
different